[Music]  why do you want to be a samurai  [Music]  i lived in a bad part of town full of  bad dogs  everybody always picked on me  i thought if i could be a samurai  it would change everything  sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a  once great samurai who has fallen on  hard times and maybe could use some help  himself  but where can i find one  get out of here who even made that it's  you don't believe everything you read  [Music]  sorry hank you have to do something  you're under arrest  you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it  get back out there  [Music]  hey this is the training montage isn't  [Applause]  don't it to land on your  feet  we've gotta wipe that towel off the map  send a tweet to assemble the troops  who knew an evil army could go through  so many bees  [Laughter]  [Applause]  time to finish this  this might take a while  [Music]  you